hello everyone and welcome to uh
something that I've never done on
leeches or anywhere else I'm going to
play a rapid game I've uh you can see
that I still have a question mark on my
rating uh since I've only played like
two of them I don't remember win I did
try playing one now just to see if it
works and if people are cheating but I
won so that's why we still have a
question mark you have to win like 20
games before actually um achieving
anything so our our opponent is abis
hammad who seems to be he does play some
blits he doesn't play a lot of bullet he
has a question mark on bullet but he
does have 1828 rapid so he is seems to
be exclusively a rapid player so we are
facing an expert here uh let's uh try to
use our time
wisely uh so I will play the
Scandinavian as I usually do I did make
a tutorial on it uh he doesn't uh seem
to be going for the center so I will
claim the uh uh D4 Square for
myself if he wants to play it now yeah
okay
maybe I don't know will'll be
interesting we'll see what he has in
mind okay so he's slow playing with
D3 I I should take a bit more time
playing my moves but these are just some
standard squares that I use for the
Scandinavian sometimes I will differ
between Bishop G4 and Bishop
F5 and um okay
so we can trade here not a
problem
uh yeah we'll even trade here no yeah
we'll yeah we'll trade
here and let's go go
here I want to play queenside castles
but even if he goes Bishop to G4 I'm
going to get my Rook into the game
simply to align it nicely with his Queen
and then we're going to slowly Castle
King side so I don't know what he will
play uh like C3 also not not a terrible
Choice
um yeah I'm going to play Rook d8 first
because if he plays C3 then I want to
move my knight and if he trades Queens I
want my Bishop to get into the game with
Tempo I don't want to lose uh lose time
doing anything yeah so now if he trades
okay if I play Bishop to E7 first then I
would play twice with the bishop okay
so yeah let's let's REM maneuver that
Queen he probably wants to attack it
anyway
okay not the move I would
guess uh also not the move I would guess
let's get our Bishop into the
game
so what's better his bishop or my knight
that that is to be decided and I I could
just you know attack it but I don't
really want to weaken my king side for
the moment uh let's put our Rook uh
Rooks on dark squares so that's what
we'll do first he'll probably play that
uh and then we'll we'll double up
so uh as long as his Bishop is here and
his Pawn is in the way way yeah probably
would have been better to do this now he
does have some issues here with ideas of
yeah okay he will defend it like this
and now we go
here yeah just winning more more squares
that's pretty much all I'm
doing we go for Queen G5
also hm
what is
this he actually he actually did that to
win my
Rook all right so it's a pretty bad
blunder but we have to also exploit it
carefully
yeah
all right so we're going to win some
nice rating here if we don't if we don't
mess it up okay so he wants to trade uh
I don't think I have anything better
other than to trade so let's trade yeah
okay just up a full
Rook very happy with how things are
going for
me
and now let's try to finish it as
quickly as
possible
uh what's what's as quickly as
possible this is as quickly as
possible there we go and now we just
deliver
mate all
right
he will block with the bishop of course
but now we can just do this there we
go I'm looking for a mate uh just not
seeing one that's
uh that's the problem is it here yeah
it's here it's here it's
here
okay uh yeah the mate was uh King G1
Knight F3 check King to H1 and Rook
captures an H2 mate all right so that
was a nice one let's try another
one yeah we get the white pieces now and
we yeah we won a lot of rating points
because we are unrated so now we are
already up to 1930 so we get like 200
rating points for a win our opponent is
Darko
uh no n 9963 sorry uh maybe Darko is
interested in some Evans Gambit action
but no he goes for the two knights so we
we're going to try we're going to see
how how deep darkos Theory really goes
all right so this is where it all
happens now you could play Queen uh
sorry you could play Queen F3 uh
standard is Bishop D2 but also you could
play Bishop to D3 sometimes they play
that uh so uh I don't play it let's play
it to see how it goes probably probably
you put it here so you can Retreat the
Knight to E4 or for some reason but now
what if he plays F5 well he probably
will get a lot of a lot of space for his
pieces um let's play
A3
best way to play this is to see why it
doesn't uh why it's bad I
guess all right let's put pressure on E5
so as usual when you play this with
white you're up
uh yeah okay uh you're up a pawn and he
will of course try to do his best
to nullify that say
F4
you can play e you can play
E4 yeah I actually prefer to play this
with black so that's why I I I really
have no idea how to do it with
white so he of course will I could have
captured here maybe first but I don't
mind giving back the
pawn yeah
I don't think that pawn will make anyone
happy so let's pile up on the
Knight of
course of course claiming the the the
open B file for your Rook that's a good
move
always yeah well I I definitely like his
position better like by a
lot uh
okay
uh yeah if I play this he's just going
to
push
h
I'm kind of hoping that the pawn pushes
are a bit too
much although they're probably
not yeah F4 here
hm yeah no reason I prefer playing this
with
black no no
wonder but okay it's rapid you have a
lot of time to okay so he doesn't want
to play it right
away uh which makes me very happy as I
get to play Bishop E5 kind of get
control of over F4 and offer some trades
here yeah let's do
that and now he still can't play F4
because I just take and then pick up the
F4
Pawn okay so equal material both players
Bishop pair I do have two Pawn Islands
he has
three uh really really weird but okay my
Bishop pair also looking very good
now okay so he does take the pawn do we
want to punish that of course we
do of course we do
would be silly not to do
it there we
go it also develops his Queen so it's
hard to say how much of a punishment
this really is uh but I don't think I
had anything better and also it will
weaken the A5 pawn it is a past Pawn for
now
H yeah very
interesting very
interesting yeah okay he really likes
his Knight on D5 and I like his Knight I
never want to capture it to you know fix
his Pawn structure so the Knight is
excellently placed
there now he's what is he considering
yeah obviously he's he he doesn't want
to move the queen away uh from defending
the A5 Pawn now he has to be careful
also The Rook is uh attack so if he
moves the queen to a weird Square
probably first he will play okay so he
goes for that first he attacks the C2
pawn and the D2
Pawn I could use this somehow to my
advantage yeah I'm going to play
C3 invite his Knight to D3 because it's
not really doing anything on D3 and then
I'm going to play Knight
F4 not much of a plan but yeah I I I
really like his Knight here so the queen
is not attacking the D2
Pawn Yeah okay I for the moment I can't
play Knight F4 if I actually invited
there so
H yeah his Knight is wow this is
probably a bad move okay so he doesn't
do that he attacks my Queen
instead oh okay where is the Knight
going if I attack
it what is
this that is a blundered
knight yeah there is no there is no way
to recover from
this he h he has to give it up somehow
but there just isn't a good way to give
it up and he can't really attack
anything all right so we're we're going
to win some more rating here not the
cleanest way to do it but you know what
are you going to
do yeah we could go over the game after
after I finish it just to see how much
how much stuff I actually missed because
probably there's a
lot um so yeah we'll do it after this
game I hope he didn't just leave that
would be that would be very
sad yeah I'm trying to play slower uh
because I actually played a lot of
bullet before starting these games um
okay so what do we want to do now
uh yeah okay let's let's get our Knight
to F4 we don't want to allow this Pawn
to come to F4 uh because that pawn
should have
uh should have come to F4 a long time
ago
um
yeah let's play Queen
C2 I want to get D3 in yeah as long as
my knight is on F4 everything is nicely
defended what is this he wants to play
he can't play that
yeah uh he can't play that we're going
to open up the position
here get my Bishop
here yeah he's still interested in the
game so of course we can't just play
anything otherwise he will uh he will
punish
us uh is
there a way a way to do this let's go
Knight D5 if he puts his Queen to a
weird Square then we can even attack it
but he doesn't oh there's actually
this yeah do I capture
first we can capture
first oh no no Rook Capt wow that was
actually silly but it it should still
work oh man I'm so so bad at executing
this
wow it's really
bad yeah I should have just played that
capture some B4 right away I thought he
was going to capture with the pawn
automatically see this is a good example
of what happens if you start celebrating
too early you miss a move and then off
goes the
game all
right yeah he knows he has to do it
otherwise although uh some Queen to
B6 was also in
there yeah he doesn't have Bishop A6
that makes me very happy and now he
wants to play Bishop A6 on the next move
but luckily we can just move our Queen
with
Tempo okay so we do win this uh do we
have to move the
Knight sure let's do
it yeah luckily even with uh all the bad
moves
uh we still got we still got a a great
game out of it another great game a
great uh you know position that we were
able to win
okay
so uh that's mate uh let's just analyze
it really
quickly uh all right so that after this
uh Knight to F5 move which was of course
very
nice no not sorry not Knight to F5 so
that's pretty standard he played this
and
that uh yeah castles is best uh says
Knight Knight G3 sort of the strongest
move A3 not the best I I knew that as I
mentioned it when I played it I just
wanted to see what the you know the the
core of the position was yeah Knight C5
not the best Knight to G3 is best but I
was afraid of the pawns okay so captures
captures yeah he is better here uh let
me just check if he had like a knockout
anywhere yeah Queen G5 he says very very
strong here obviously he played this A5
move and allowed me Bishop to E5
all right still yeah Bishop captures on
A3 obviously not not the best Bishop
captures on G7 is the
refutation uh okay okay okay he goes
here yeah C3 the move I was uh
considering actually the strongest and
says winning for white see I don't know
why but I played it he went here Queen
to C1 yeah okay obviously uh it's bad if
um if he plays this because he blunders
the Knight but if he went here
oh then it was great because simply
captures captures and Knight F4 just
winning this Square it's an a dark
Square you can't kick it away there are
no pawns so uh as you win the monster
Square for the Knight that's why it's uh
so strong so yeah but here also I was
interested uh
yeah oh here actually just Queen to
B2 once I play this Rook captures yeah
still Knight captures on B4 yeah okay
everything works everything works so uh
he had he was better uh should have
taken advantage of it but you know what
are you going to do all right so we can
play one more how much rating did we get
we got 100 rating points for this win
very nice okay so we can play one more
it's going to be a pretty long video but
uh yeah I have to get that rapid
rating uh our next opponent is uh
intimus 2144 okay and he challenges us
to E4 which means the
Scandinavian okay okay
so uh I actually don't know how to play
this uh I have I have a way of of how I
usually play it but I don't know if
that's the proper way to play it we're
just going to trade and now if he
captures I'm going to play Bishop
captures and play C5 simply to fight for
the D4 Square uh that's my plan if he
yeah if he captured there then I would
just start
thinking uh so even a queen trade huh
wow
yeah let's go B6
so
uh do I like Bishop's traded no I don't
no I really
don't yeah let's go let's go here for
the moment I don't think he can take
advantage of
me slow playing
it uh okay so we've doubled one set of
his pawns do we want to double another
set of his
pawns and he really afford
that yeah he can't go here otherwise we
trap his Bishop so he goes here okay
uh and we go no we don't play this oh
almost did a terrible thing
there almost did a terrible thing there
yeah now if he plays that I can simply
tra no h see I could trade but then he
captures I can give a check he goes
back uh you
know worst case scenario he UND doubles
his
pawns yeah okay G4 I don't mind playing
this uh
my Bishop is actually fine here if he
wants to yeah okay you can play that you
can play that let's
go yeah see my my king isn't on the
great on the on the best Square there
H his Bishop pair could annoy me a lot
here yeah but it is what we wanted to
play yeah okay he does get Rooks on the
D file but we'll be able to play E6 get
our King to E7 and then uh get get the
other Rook into the game and defend if
he goes Bishop to G5 we don't really
care uh we're going to play F6 okay so
he does that as well very
nice uh okay King
E7
sure
sure sure I like
it
um
H
yeah
H yeah I don't like it I kind of feel
feel I have to play
this I don't know
why yeah okay I don't see all that many
great jumps for his Knight and what does
he want to do with the Rook he can't
double up he could play here uh I could
play F6 F6 looks very nice
uh or I could simply play Knight F6
which wins the
pawn yeah okay but he's going to trade
Rooks I capture he goes Knight E5 to
attack my F7 pawn and if I go back he
has Knight to C6
check I go here and no more checks for
him he could harass my kingside pawns
though is it worth
it
yeah I don't
know
oh all
right okay
okay so his King is a bit more active
let's play F5 simply so my knight and
the pawns cut off the king completely
and then we get the king into the
game ah so we've equalized in material
and now we fight against his doubled
Pawn okay so he stops
this uh yeah let's just get our King
into the
game sure
sure yeah the that's the
best
uh let's do
this okay so our Knight should
definitely join the fun over
there okay let's go here yeah he can't
go there
really let's go
here okay what is the Knight doing there
let's grab more space again pawn and
Knight controlling
everything I like
it okay so he hones in on this
Pawn
uh
let's defend it it' be it's a bit silly
to defend it with your
king yeah he could play this also which
is very
nice uh but I have a knight and it can
probably be very quick about you know
getting uh all the way here to helping
out with the defense yeah he will play
that of course he will uh I have to take
here now and take here do I have to take
here do we throw in a check first no we
have to
take
[Music]
um if I move I run into a check so
that's out of the question we have to
take and he will take with the Knight of
course
if he pushes I might even give up my
knight
okay
yeah sorry about
that uh yeah I mean obviously a nice
draw what are you going to do is there a
way no there's
no okay so we're going to quickly go
through what we did I mean it wasn't a
very exciting game let me just check
here all right so uh yeah nothing wrong
there uh yeah perfectly fine okay okay
yeah
so DC3 F captures on G7 oh so it's it's
better to actually play C captur on D2
okay something I have to remember for
future uh yeah and C5 doesn't really
work here it's uh already a much better
position for him yeah
and you
probably also had this feeling that it
was uh much much harder to play this uh
for me yeah he he doubled up here very
nicely okay so you went for
that yeah now H5 was just giving up all
of the
advantage uh yeah so if anyone should
have won this it it was definitely
him
okay so yeah it's uh I'm better here in
this end game but there's no actual way
of doing anything about it if anything
yet is perfectly fine still a dead draw
dead draw dead
draw yeah I was just wondering if there
was some sort of a big Miss anywhere but
no he had a much better game and I
somehow equalized and that's pretty much
it but we still got like 25 points for
for a draw against him so not uh not bad
uh two and a half out of three you know
we'll uh we'll continue this tomorrow uh
already a 30 minute video but uh yeah I
wanted to get some rapid games in and um
you know get a get an actual rapid
rating so I'm going to make three games
tomorrow as well uh we'll see how it
goes uh and yeah I also learned
something uh for example I never knew
that here uh for this was a lot of fun
that I you should actually play this for
some reason that it's yeah this I guess
gives white uh just too much development
for his Bishops as those Bishops really
gave me a really hard time uh but yeah
those are the games hope you guys
enjoyed them uh hope you learned from
them you know if you if you uh found the
way on how to improve all all the better
uh so yeah we'll try this tomorrow and
uh see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day